Facebook founder, Mark Zuckerberg imploded
recently when he was questioned by Congresswoman
Alexandria Castillio courts has a few weeks
ago we covered it for you and it's getting
worse because we learned not long ago that
Donald Trump and Mark Zuckerberg had a meeting.
Now it was initially a secret meeting in the
sense that it didn't appear on Donald Trump's
schedule anywhere.
Facebook didn't report that this meeting between
Trump and Zuckerberg had taken place.
Eventually news of the meeting did surface
thanks to N a an NBC news report and of course
only then did Facebook say, well yeah, we
did actually have that meeting and it was
actually back in October when Zuckerberg had
that terrible appearance before Congress.
So Mark Zuckerberg appears on CBS this morning
yesterday and is interviewed by Gail King
and Gayle King asks him about the meeting
and Zuckerberg devolves into just meaningless
stuttering.
Visibly uncomfortable.
It is not good.
Take a look.
You were in DC recently there, it was reported
later that you had dinner with the president
of the white house.
What was the nature of the meeting?
Can you say?
Uh, sure.
I mean, we talked about, um, uh, a number
of things that were, that were on his mind
and, um, and some of the topics that you'd
read about in the news around, around, um,
our work,
we talked about a number of things and topics
in the news.
Super clear, Mark, crystal clear.
I, I totally understand it.
And she tried to follow up on the question
and it actually gets even worse.
People would say the optics weren't good.
Did he try to lobby you in any way?
No.
I mean, I don't think that that's that I think
some of the stuff that people talk about or
think gets discussed in these discussions
are not really how, okay.
How that works.
I also want to respect that it was a private,
dedicated Brendan's prior discussion.
Did
he lobby you?
Uh, no.
Um, some stuff people talk about things that,
uh, you know, it's not always as discussed,
so I get it.
It was a private meeting.
That's not a defense though.
That's actually part of the problem as I see
it.
Donald Trump has publicly talking about Facebook
should do this, Facebook should do that.
Facebook should not do this other thing.
Zuckerberg testifies before Congress on exactly
the same issues.
It's a train wreck that gives off vibes that
this is truly a terribly bad faith actor.
They keep the meeting, not just private but
secret.
They're outed.
And then he says a meaningless word salad
and says, you know, it was a private meeting.
Anyway, so I have to be careful.
Now.
I do actually think that Donald Trump and
Zuckerberg probably, uh, did not plan nefarious
things in the meeting.
Don't think it's that explicit.
I mean, they may be nefarious in some ways,
but if you're imagining this cartoonish secret
meeting where they're whispering about all
of the nefarious things they're going to do
on Facebook to help Donald Trump there, I
don't think that anything that cartoonish
or dramatic took place.
This is just how the hubs of power continue
chugging along.
Peter teal was also at the meeting, which
only raises even more red flags.
That's a story for another day.
If you don't know who Peter teal is, I envy
you.
Uh, that, that's great.
Uh, now let me propose one thing that would
be maybe, maybe the only thing that makes
Mark Zuckerberg word salad answer a little
bit less disturbing.
Trump often doesn't know what the hell he's
talking about and nobody around him does.
Is it possible that the reason Mark Zuckerberg
struggled to say what was discussed is because
he didn't understand what on earth Donald
Trump was talking about?
Is that maybe why he was unable to answer
Gayle King's question?
I'm kidding.
Sort of mostly, but who knows.
My guess is that the topics from that meeting
will ultimately play a role in the 2020 election.
There's too much at stake right now.
The dynamics, the power dynamics of what a
platform like Facebook can do when it comes
to influencing elections by virtue of what
they do and don't allow.
The stakes are extremely high and I would
be shocked if whatever was discussed between
Trump and Zuckerberg doesn't ultimately play
a role in the 2020 election.
Let me know what you think was talked about.